[Musique]
didier baichère bonjour pour ce café
politique ici à montigny le bretonneux
un look to you qui nous reçoit
montigny-le-bretonneux qui fait partie
de votre circonscription où il est
député de la première circonscription
l'adhésine line montigny guyancourt et
versailles également vous siégez sous
les couleurs république en marche
vous avez à découvert l'assemblée il ya
quelques mois maintenant ça s'est passé
comment cette découverte très différent
du monde du travail donc c'est à la fois
comme un nouveau travail donc on a des
nouveaux collègues on a un nouveau lieu
de travail donc il faut s'adapter à une
nouvelle culture dans toutes les
entreprises ont des cultures l'assemblée
par contre c'est très différent d'un
travailleur moi j'ai toujours été
salarié dans le secteur privé
majoritairement il ya des codes
il ya des rythmes et
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses
d'ailleurs qui conduisent françois de
rugy maintenant à vouloir travailler une
transformation profonde de l'assemblée
parce que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ne sont plus adaptées à ce
que ce qu'on doit faire et au rythme on
doit traiter l'évolution des lois par
exemple c'est trop c'est trop long c'est
trop complexe c'est trop long il ya
énormément d'allers-retours par exemple
entre le sénat et
et le parlement
vous avez des dizaines d'amendements qui
vont être déposées sur le même sujet et
donc les députés qui vont défendre ces
amendements vont utiliser des dizaines
de fois les mêmes arguments
le texte va partir au sénat va être
amendé va revenir les mêmes amendements
vont être déposés les mêmes arguments
votre développer donc en fait son chemin
je suis pas persuadé qui est de
l'efficacité
vous avez rejoint très tôt le mouvement
en marche
mobilisés sur le secteur de cette 1ère
circonscription avons ensuite d'avoir
l'investiture et puis et puis d'être élu
député
lorsque vous vous êtes engagés sur ce
projet cette idée d' emmanuel macron
vous êtes dit on est bien parti vous
étiez confiant donc dans quel état
d'esprit parce que il ya eu un
raz-de-marée ensuite il ya eu cette
victoire à la présidentielle il ya eu ce
scrutin législatif qui a été très
favorable au parti du président des
débuts où vous avez cru pleinement dans
ce projet qu'est ce qui vous a motivé
pour le rejoindre
wen a eu un formidable espoir après
c'est je pense que chacun va avoir une
histoire
différentes a raconté moi j'ai eu la
chance de croiser emmanuel macron quand
il était ministre de l'économie
et parce qu'il organisait des événements
en fait à bercy où il invitait les
citoyens jeudi c'était aussi simple que
ça on pouvait aller assister à des
débats que lui monnaie et donc j'ai été
séduit en fait par la simplicité
l'efficacité et la volonté d'être
pragmatique et de et de changer les
choses pour que ça touche les
entrepreneurs ou les salariés enfin
voilà qui fait donc ça ça m'a c'est ce
qui m'a intéressé à l'origine après
l'aventuré en marche rien n'était gagné
je pense que personne personne ne
pouvait prédire le succès au goût mais
on a une démarche qui était très très
modeste et il va pragmatique voilà on
repart des basiques alors c'est vrai que
moi en étant conseiller municipal à
versailles dans l'opposition à
versailles
j'ai pu aussi touchés c'est quoi
l'environnement politique c'est quoi les
clivages c'est quoi les postures de
droite et de gauche et je les dis
souvent moi c'est des choses qui me
convenait pas quand j'ai commencé en
avec ce premier mandat à la mairie de
car je n'y ai jamais trouvé mon compte
dans les postures de criblage et on a vu
c'est ça qui a fait le succès dans
marche c'est que ni à gauche ni à droite
voilà on disait pas bonjour je suis de
droite bonjour suite gauche en est je
viens travailler sur l'éducation
je viens travailler sur qu'est ce que
j'imagine 2
quel sera mon député demain et quelle
mission je veux qu'ils remplissent et
comment je veux qu'ils se comportent
c'était des sujets qui étaient
fédérateur et qui voilà qui intéressait
des citoyens de manière générale et donc
c'est comme ça qu'on a qu'on a construit
le mouvement mais la grande marche
qu'elle fait qu'on allait il a été
interviewé les gens on leur a demandé
qu'est ce qu'ils aimaient hockey ce
qu'ils aimaient pas en france
aujourd'hui c'est un moment des changes
qui est rare et beaucoup de partis
politiques ont perdu de vue
on vit entre soi dans les partis
politiques très vite sonné entre
militants et voilà on touche plus
forcément le citoyen
au quotidien et je pense qu'on peut
perdre les l'ordre des priorités mais
aujourd'hui en marche on présente le
mouvement plutôt comme à droite en tout
cas qui pénalise la droite c'est ce qui
est ressorti quelques fois de l'opinion
par rapport à certaines déclarations ou
par certaines mesures également il ya eu
cette déclaration sur les sur les
fainéants par exemple des manuels macron
oui alors quand je vois l'état de la
gauche je me dis que finalement je ne
sais pas qui paye le plus cher tribut
dans cette histoire là aussi c'est pas
une histoire de droite et de gauche
c'est une histoire que les citoyens ont
envie de décisions qui les touchent au
quotidien les entrepreneurs ils veulent
de la régularité de la constance et
comprendre où est ce qu'on les emmène
c'est ça la différence et les parties
peut enfin moi je vais vous dire je suis
je suis fils vice président de l'office
des sciences et des technologies avec
cédric villani qui est le président de
cet office c'est une seule office en
fait qui est paritaire entre le sénat et
l'assemblée et l'assemblée nationale
je vois la très très grande différence
entre mes collègues qui sont
parlementaires souvent nouveaux
parlementaires qui viennent d'arriver
dans cet office et des sénateurs qui
sont plus extrêmement longtemps dans cet
office le rythme qu'ils se sont donnés
la manière dont il travaille sur des
sujets comme la bioéthique comme
l'intelligence artificielle qui sont les
sujets de demain pour nous ils sont pas
dans le rythme ils ont perdu
complètement pied par rapport à la
réalité du monde extérieur
et ça c'est pas la droite et la gauche
ça c'est la nécessité de reprendre les
dossiers par rapport à l'objectif qui
est attendue par les citoyens
quel est l'objectif de transformation
qu'est ce qui est bon ou pas pour la
france qu'est ce qui est bon pour les
entreprises pour les demandeurs d'emploi
un moment donné pour l'insertion va j'en
viens à votre parcours au civil en tout
cas vous êtes des rajouts l'avait
mentionné à des entreprises plutôt
technologies et et et défense vous avez
mis entre parenthèses cette activité
professionnelle oui oui c'est juste une
parenthèse est ce que c'est juste une
parenthèse moi je n'en sais rien oui
c'est une parenthèse moi je le vis comme
ça
après on verra bien ce qui se passera ce
qui se passera pas mais c'est aussi
important de le vivre comme une
parenthèse est donc dans cinq ans
potentiellement je reprendrai mon
travail de drh dans l'entreprise où
j'étais jusque là que vous n'êtes pas
dans l'optique de vous dire j'ai été élu
j'y suis arrivé je vais rester j'ai un
deux trois mandats pour travailler non
mais j'avais une vie beaucoup plus
simple quand j'ai été drh
non franchement pas mais maintenant peut
être que au bout de cinq ans on n'aura
pas fait suffisamment de chemin on
n'aura pas suffisamment transformé et si
les électeurs font confiance et
peut-être que je me représenterai jeu
franchement je n'en sais rien et c'est
vraiment pas le sujet du moment le sujet
du moment c'est à l'avancé on a des
réformes importantes à mener pour le
budget 2010 8 et il faut qu'elle avance
et pour notre territoire il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses cela je le vois le
lundi et le vendredi je suis sur la
circonscription et je rencontre beaucoup
d'acteurs qu'ils soient associatifs les
politiques bien sûr les maires des
communes leur équipe
on a beaucoup de travail parmi les
différents secteurs qui vous intéresse
on a toujours un petit peu des choses
qui nous intéresse plus que d'autres
c'est le travail sur la jeunesse
peut-être parce que je regardais aussi
par rapport à votre votre parcours vous
aviez également
une association pour rapprocher les
jeunes avec handicap de tuteurs salariés
par exemple donc la jeunesse c'est un
secteur qui qui vous attire plus
particulièrement
moi je vais je vais travailler beaucoup
là donc je démarre donc un groupe
parlementaire sur l'apprentissage et et
la filière d'excellence technologique et
un autre travaille alors plus de faune
pour lequel j'ai commencé des auditions
qui est l'inclusion économique c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné et on le voit
beaucoup sur notre territoire peut-être
plus saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
manière générale on a énormément de
jeunes qui sont issus de quartiers dits
compliqué difficile on va pas les
stigmatiser qui font leurs études par
exemple l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines qui sortent diplômés et qui se
retrouvent par rapport à leur lieu
d'habitation stigmatisés et ont du mal à
trouver un emploi c'est concret et les
statistiques il ya 50% de ces jeunes de
plus qui sont qui sont au chômage
donc je en train de travailler sur
comment un moment donné on peut amener
les entreprises à recruter naturellement
ces jeunes là c'est une mission que
j'avais déjà en tant que drh des gens
comme mozaïk rh kit qui travaille sur
ces sujets depuis très longtemps
passeport avenir
donc oui je me vais travailler langue de
la jeunesse sous l'angle de redonner de
l'excellence à la filière technologique
tout le monde ne peut pas continuer à
aller vers la filière j'ai envie de dire
polyvalente autonome classique d'études
et se retrouver en échec après une année
d'université
donc il faut redonner c'est un débat
qu'on a eu à la pré rentrée scolaire
avec les professeurs des minimes
breteuil j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
une après midi ils font ce constat émis
de breteuil ils ont la chance d'être un
lycée polyvalent
donc ils ont la filière classique ils
ont la filière d'enseignement
professionnel et réoriente énormément de
jeunes avec beaucoup de succès en tout
début de seconde
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à faire cette
orientation de manière positive
vous avez trois enfants ces enfants-là
voulez-vous y regrette pas de voir leur
père un peu moins 13 ans justement parce
que vous disiez la vie était plus facile
avant pour vous entendre drh
je pensais que j'étais plus présent et
drh je voyageais beaucoup donc j'avais
beaucoup de déplacements en france et à
l'étranger donc non je suis faire le
temps le temps de présence n'a pas n'a
pas augmenté ou diminué en mars que le
rythme est différent c'est voilà c'est
un autre type de un autre type de rythme
on est on est député en fait 7 jours sur
7 et 24 heures sur 24
et lorsqu'il y était là comme la départ
exemple des des filières technologiques
des choses comme ça pour orienter les
plus jeunes vouloir en parler
vous avez leur retour vous avez leur
écot oui je les regarde je les regarde
depuis qu'ils sont nés je me nourris
aussi dû
voilà de leur expérience de leur
réussite de leurs échecs des difficultés
qu'ils ont pu rencontrer
voilà moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un fils
qui dès le jour il est rentré à l'école
on m'a dit qu'il n'était pas adapté pour
l'école et que donc il fallait qu'on
trouve un autre moyen pour les
scolariser
il a passé un bac s il aujourd'hui dans
une école de commerce et il est premier
de sa promotion
voilà elle en troisième année d'école de
commerce donc voilà je suis de suite je
pense qu'il faut être attentif le rythme
des enfants il est différent d'un enfant
à l'autre d'une famille à l'autre
à l'école elle est globale et elle n'a
pas toujours le temps de voilà
d'attendre de s'occuper de l'enfant les
enfants c'est pour ça que là aussi on
est amené à prendre des mesures simples
pragmatiques dédoubler les classes de cp
les classes de ce1 et progressivement
essayer de diminuer le nombre d'élèves
dans les classes cc ces sujets là très
concrets qui vont faire qu'on aura du
succès demain dans les écoles je reste
sur cette question de la jeunesse parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'attentes de la part
de la jeunesse
on l'a vu lors du dernier scrutin encore
présidentielle il y avait une abstention
qui a été malgré tout importante là
aujourd'hui on a presque le sentiment
que c'est le message qui a été passé
pendant la campagne présidentielle que
c'est la dernière chance en fait pour la
classe politique de se réconcilier aussi
avec les jeunes est de ramener les
électeurs aux urnes aujourd'hui vous
avez le sentiment que ce message passe
donc le mouvement s'essouffle déjà qui a
déjà des déçus qui va falloir retourner
sur le terrain aussi faire de la
pédagogie qu'il n'a jamais quitté le
terrain en fait et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'oublie pas si reconnaît on
a été élus sur cette formidable envie de
changement de dialogue et de
co-construction donc la jeunesse donc
les jeunes avec macron les jardins avec
moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé pendant
cette campagne continue à être présent
jeu sans rentrer dans le détail mais
j'ai un comité politique d'une dizaine
de personnes qui représente 6 à 3
personnes par vivre de la
circonscription qui a trois
conscription on se réunit tous les
lundis soirs il ya des jeunes
il ya des moins jeunes dans ce comité
politique donc c'est à la fois une
représentation de nos communes mais une
représentation des classes d'âge des
différents types de métiers jeu
challenge avec eux tous les lundis soirs
les textes sur lequel je travaille à
l'assemblée nationale demain et c'est le
travail qu'on est en train de faire avec
eux comment on va faire pour ouvrir ce
débat moi je peux pas continuer à parler
que des gens dans marche je suis le
député de tout le monde donc il faut il
faut l'ouvrir
ben je vais discuter avec les
professeurs et des mines breteuil je
rencontre des jeunes sur les marchés
j'ai la chance aussi de pouvoir
intervenir dans des écoles suis je suis
intervenir il ya quinze jours dans un
master 2 en alternance de communication
politique c'est des moments d'échangés
avec les jeunes qui sont très très fort
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
méconnaissance non pas de leurs attentes
mais aussi de quelle est notre travail
et quelles sont les capacités enfin ce
sur quoi on peut changer faire bouger
les lignes
et ça c'est un travail de pédagogique
qui s'est montré humble je dois aller
expliquer ce que je fais je dois me
retrouver en position d'être au
challenge et par par la jeunesse est
extrêmement important on va terminer
cette émission avec un petit
questionnaire rapide d'actualité au sens
large je vais vous demander de choisir
diesel ou essence je peux pas choisir
l'électricité vous pouvez ce sera
lectrices ite vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au château de
versailles
j'ai passé plus de temps au vélodrome
qu'au château de versailles château de
versailles en fait c'est plus un endroit
familial pour moi parce que voilà je
j'habite à côté
gcs voilà c'est un lieu de vie de
balades de vélo par contre pendant la
campagne j'ai passé plus de temps au
vélodrome à le découvrir et avoir son
importance dans l'écosystème économique
donc aller vers l'autre vélodrome
surtout qu'avec les jo de 2024 qui qui
maintenant sont officielles pour pour
paris et pour saint quentin en yvelines
le dernier maire ou député parce qu'il y
aura un scrutin municipal dans quelques
années aussi et vous aviez déjà
candidater à l'époque vous serez
candidat à nouveau le savait déjà
vous êtes déjà posé la question à mon
nom alors là voilà j'ai travaillé mon
travail de député je me projette dans
rien de l'année mais par contre je me
projette parfaitement dans la
construction et le positionnement dans
marche dans les yvelines
ça c'est extrêmement important c'est
quelque chose que je ne vais pas lâcher
et on a des forces à construire à
versailles comme ailleurs à montigny à
guyancourt ont construit actuellement
des troupes pour mener les combats qui
vont arriver les municipales et d'autres
au nom de marche mais ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai merci didier baichère dès
qu'ils allaient république en marge de
la première circonscription des yvelines
café politique et à revoir sur tv 78 sur
notre application mobile également
n'hésitez pas à nous faire part de vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux et
à très bientôt toujours ici à l'hôptal
ou à montigny-le-bretonneux
[Musique]